our animal friends return in Madagascar
escaped to Africa I really hate movie
titles that have the number in the title
for example escape 2 Africa does it
really make things in the easier
Madagascar 2 there that was a lot
shorter and a lot simpler but anyway
how's the movie fare out the first one I
thought was funny particularly in the
animation Department in this one well
seems to be a little funnier it knows
what to do with its characters and knows
how to keep fresh jokes coming and it
knows how to keep a fast pace but also
keep a good heart the film starts out
exactly where it left off with our
heroes still stuck on the island but
they figure out an almost foolproof way
to get themselves back by repairing the
plane and putting it on a giant
slingshot this doesn't quite get them
back to New York but it does get them to
Africa where everyone seems to fit in
really really well the lion is reunited
with his mother and father the hippo
finds a new love the giraffes
germophobia up great scent doctor and
the zebra matches to fit into maybe even
a little too well things start to come
undone though when the lion it turns out
has to pass some sort of test in order
to stay in the herd blood seeing how
he's a performer and not really a
survivor he finds that task is much
harder than it seems and the rest of our
heroes also find that there's downsides
to their paradise as well will they stay
and work it out or is it time to move on
to movie number three well seeing how
movie number three has them in Europe I
think it's kind of a safe bet to assume
what's gonna happen but again what makes
it good is in what comedic ways it
happens and once again the movie really
shines in the comedy and the animation
it's got some low points like I'm
finding out more and more that Jada
Pinkett Smith and David Schwimmer
characters are not especially
interesting at least not in the joke
Department I also think the villain is
kind of weak well maybe not weak just
not funny
Alec Baldwin does a good job playing a
slimy unlikable detestable creature and
he's also good in the movie too hahaha I
digress he actually does do a good job
it's just I would have liked a little
bit more comedy to come out of him
that's Bernie Mac playing the Lions
father doing a surprisingly very
heartfelt performance
not too many funny lines come out of him
but it still feels very genuine I'm
finding more and more of my favorite
character out of these movies is the
zebra something about Chris rocks lines
and his delivery and his performance
I don't know it just cracks me up he's
so likeable and energetic and in this
one just having a million Chris rocks
talk I don't know that just really
cracks me up for some reason hey exactly
is a oh and guess who else is back that
crazy old lady that just had a quick
cameo in the first one but now she's
like one of the main characters she
leads an abandoned safari hunt group but
to the tourists almost go Lord of the
Flies and by God she has just determined
to find this lion again I don't know
what her beef is but she just kills me
and that's one of the movie's strong
points it knows when to keep continuing
jokes which characters to hold on to but
also knows when to add new material and
up the ante it isn't just a rehash it
gives us exactly what we want while also
mixing it with new things
the result is an energy filled funny
comedy I find myself really enjoying
these movies they just don't seem like
other animated flicks out there they
seem to really take advantage of the
fact that it's animation they can do
slapstick they can do verbal humor they
can do heart they can just throw
whatever they want without feeling they
had to conform to say the Disney style
or the Pixar style or heck even soar the
dreamwork style and it seems to balance
out really really well if you're not fan
of the first one I don't think the
second one will really sway you at all
but if you do like the first one the
second one is more the same great comedy
while also upping the new stuff I say
check it out I have some fun
Oh